うちの周りはリベラルがうろうろしとる
近くの児童相談所がやってきてねざて20
人もや来るんや子供の権利を守るために
子供保護せて色々お前今の言葉にはもう
すでにおかしいとかあるよそれお前ら
ごときが何よ意なことやっとるんや待って
待て宿題出してる権利の定義をしてこい3
日以内にしてこい力は全に決まっとる
じゃんこんなもんや
ね結局ね今うまくいかのは常識が間違っ
とるんやね今の常識がだから当たり前の
ように体罰は悪だって言うじゃないいじめ
は悪だって言うじゃん体罰の定義はいじめ
の定義は目的はみんなそれぞれ目的がある
んよね人間の行動っていうのはその目的も
知らずにさ言葉を羅列するだけでことを
すすというのが今の特にマスコミの態度や
ね彼らの言いたいのは私たちはいい人で
すって言いたいわけ奴らのために教育が
あるわけはないよねから奴らをいい人だと
みんなが認めるためにあんなわけのわから
ん理論があるわけよ
ね力というものこれは絶対に必要なもんな
んや力の定義をしっかりしないともう1つ
はね使い方目的どう力を使うのか何のため
に使うのかそういうことを全く考えずに
ロンを進めていくやろだから今力は悪に
なっちまっとるよねこが力は全に決まっ
とるじゃんだから人間にあるんだからそう
いうことよねからもっとね自分の言ってる
ことをしっかりと物を分かってよう
よ前こういうのがあった近くの児童相談所
がやってきてねざと20人もや来るんや
これでいきなり入ってきてな上に上がって
こようとすもんでこらお前ら黙って人の
うちに入りやがって住居侵入やないか何し
に来たいんやまず挨拶をして許可を取って
それからにせそれがごく当たり前の社会の
通年やないそしたらえ実は言もんまええ
からともかく並べ言ってみんな定文の上に
並ばしてね20人
ずら代表者おれへんねお前行けお前行け
言って勢で来ると強いくせに1人になると
全然だめないこれいや役に務まらんよ力の
使い方が分かってない何のために力がある
か分かってない自分たちが権力を与えられ
とるじゃんその力をどう使うか
や例えばな北海道の熊がおるようなところ
で10人か20人のブラがあってさそこに
住んどる子供が幼稚ぐらいの子供が親と
一緒に東京に出てきたで親はどうしても
ちょっと行かないか子供1人そこに置い
ていかないか渋谷の八光前においかんだよ
ねでその時に子供は寂しいもんで子供に
ピストル渡してね怖かったら打てって言っ
てらみんな打っちまうよ怖いんだからこれ
は弱いものは力を使う能力がないという
ことないそうよねだからまず本人が強く
ならんことには力を使っ
てそうすると今我々が考える役人ぞ同級生
のクラスの中でも役になりたいというのは
安全思考でんでも平らに平らにという力
はけません暴力はけませんそういうタイプ
のやつばっかりじゃん役にになりたいのは
自分の安全測るためやね弱いそれが力を
持っとる使い方がろな使い方せんていう
ことね弱いものいじめになっ
ちまうそういうやつがやってきてね俺に
ちょっと怒られたらみんな震え上がっ
ちまってそこへずらっと一列に並んだ代表
者言っても出てこえへんねみんな代表じゃ
なりたくない怒られるからじゃこっちが
指名するわと1番変な格好したやつを中身
が長くてなカにもという感じのリベラルと
いう感じのやつがおっともんであお前いや
私なんかうるさいよお前そんな格好つけ
とるんやからそれないのことはできるん
やろ何しに来たんだったらいやここで子供
の権利が侵害されてるという報告があった
もんでその子供を保護しに来たっていうん
やね子供の権利を守るために子供保護
せん定色々お前今の言葉にはもうすでに
おかしいとあるよそれはな報告やないち
りって言うんだうちの周りはリベラルが
うろうろしとるなんかあったらすぐに警察
型にしようとしてな待ち構えとるん1番目
がそのそれはちくりであって報告じゃない
結局証拠がない証拠もないのにお前ら
乗り込んできてもええのか力を行使しても
ええのか警察でもできないよそれはお前ら
ごときが何よ生きなことやっとるんや反
民主主義やないいやお前ついでに聞いてる
けど民主主義の定義できんやろできません
て役人やめろで次権利とは何なんや権利を
定義してみいよそのまとみんな集まってひ
ひひ喋ってお前今まで分からんだったやつ
が急に分かるわけないやろお前らが権利と
は何かを知らずに権利の侵害だと言って
その権利の侵害をやめろと言うんだだっ
たら我々はどうしたらいいんじゃ権利とは
こうなんだから反するようなことをやめて
くれっていそれならええよ権利ってなんか
知らやつが権利を侵害するな言ったって
言われた方はどうしたらいいんやけど今
マスコミのバカや役人どもが言ってんのは
そういうことやね自分は何にも分からんの
や分からんけど流行りの言葉に従って
マスコミが流行らせるんやから流るわない
それに違反しとるといっちゃうもんていう
んやね情けなと思わんかなはい言っと
出直すか出直しまていう待って待て宿題
出してる権利の定義をしてこい3日以内に
してこいお前ら人の権利を守るのが子供の
権利を守るのが仕事だ言っとるんだから
権利は何か知らなけれ仕事できんやないか
3日や分かったな言ったらはいつってね
みんなこうやって帰ってったよこんなもん
やでそいつらがどうやって子供の教育を
するんや権利について教えるのがだいう
世界人権宣言読んだら書いてあるやね権利
と自由についてしっかり教えろて書いて
あるあれ条約だよ守らにゃねだけど権利と
は何か知らない自由とは何か知らない人間
が権利と自由について子供に教えることが
できるわけないじゃんやめないかんね
あいつら
ねDET